is not advocating
does not end their fight for justice it
does not end their feeling that they
were in
c'mon
and that they were child pictures
so today they
what happened to that
I also read
from other clients either could not be
here today we're here today
identified
and they have a right to their privacy
and we should all respect there
they also asked the court
consider leaving the record open even
though
Epstein
or my submission of a statement to allow
those victims who've not yet
there are many defendants um
context
to be able
are able to submit their victim impact
statement essentially that's what he
needs to
so we'll have to see about that
there was a suggestion about an
investigation which would be conducted
by the core team should be circumstances
mr. epsteen death
there isn't an ongoing investigation of
course but inspector general by the
United States Department of Justice and
by mr. epsteen capacity
but I did feel that it would and
the confidence of the public if the
court would
what supervised for conduct I should say
an investigation ancient circumstances
just because I believe that the wall of
the victims have had the public have a
right to know the truth whatever that
truth is right now there your questions
and answers right now nobody really
knows what the truth is
just a lot of questions raised and I'm
not going to go through those questions
now because today's really about the
victims
what they said
that's what's public hearing
I don't
well I'm going to say it today as a day
of power strength
that's all thank you
oh definitely we will be fine
I dunno we're gonna work through these
what some people might call the legal
technicalities which turn out to be
extremely important but we will be fine
we are gonna take appropriate action
I expect within the next two weeks
a lot of uses for that
we want our clients to have access to
the courts to vindicate their rights
does it seem that mr. Epstein made it
more difficult to into his estate
protection I can't read what was in this
we set up the trust I'm also not going
to
and whether his assets whether the trust
is valid whether you know where other
assets might be located
but that could be part of our
investigation so that we have everything
which is about all of that
emotional state well
representing a number of clients each
has a different feeling about it I think
all of them were very happy vision for
I'm going to call it a unique
opportunity for the victims to encourage
usually there's a victim impact
statement after the prostitution after
the conviction either by rain please or
by way of the judgment the court of law
here the prosecution was more because of
the
dependence
so it was very
and invitation from the court last week
last week and I was just amazed
because they've never received that
practice
he's come to New York
and that would be whether or not you
know any different
oh of course
Kame not overcome
short notice but that was great
I talked to the United States
emphasizing that I was very young
that obviously that there was mention a
token co-conspirators in the original
indictment
granted obviously going to be
what was going to happen to that and
hardly do be going to continue
I know their kitchen because some of my
clients is looking to law enforcement
but we have dates we're different
so
will be another indictment
doesn't when there's sufficient evidence
[Music]
so I do feel that
are very serious I mean they're working
all the time
one of the weekends their computer pods
that you mean calling me and I'm
contacting Evan
nights always there working
I just just boring if you're going to
just store puts her name
well I'm only gonna talk about the ones
that I read
so I rep today
I it was a five altogether
I would err she overheard my client but
then there's some
motor more than that why didn't you just
spoke what was her name
I think did you say
good here in March go to the AL a Davi
yes
Allen Hershkowitz accused many of the
beginning line right here in March when
you say to a leadership
well I certainly know
the best
I would challenge him to meet with any
of my clients
be willing to meet with me
open their eyes
and then he can make his judgment based
on evidence because I know Allen cares a
lot about evidence and credibility
if I were to do that
obviously if I had built
put very careful
but I can't
that some of my clients have been
willing to speak to others in the course
was not very important anyone who has
evidence relevant across nation should
speak to law enforcement but what
anybody speaks to law enforcement they
are under a legal duty to talk truth
and I do feel that my clients exposure
to the United States Attorney and the
investigators so far
my understanding is that the United
States Attorney's Office
or at least at the prosecutors who have
spoken with them and also it's not just
about one-on-one
after evidences
some of my clients have to cooperate
such as photographs such as
other individual
you know they were there they're so
the patterning practice loose out there
on dog
so having said that I invite Alan to
meet with them and oversee be there and
we change in time if that's what he
thinks answers that my clients so it's
no way you would have of judging them or
their credibility and I'm going to give
them the benefit of the doubt and he's
not talking
I don't know whether it is Maxwell is
cooperating
what
what should the consequences be for
government prosecutors prosecutors who
violate enterprise
are you talking the prosecutors were
talking about that mm government
mr. Epstein
I mean obviously that call
also the different drugs team heard the
arguments by its fourth edition who were
not provided an opportunity to
any knowledge of the 21st entered
he said that
what's violating who violated when they
bottle it why they buy
and so as to what consequences should be
if anyone did violate either
I don't want to ever get
I think
she doesn't yeah well the baby is not
giving a statement today a moment is not
either what mama wasn't or
probably one of the few times she's
everything
so what maybe t-shirts they can say that
it says it says strong like mom
she's five and a half months so now the
moment is not wish to see the statement
she is it's important to her to bring a
baby because she has no child care and
she got two baby
and so
great parents and a brief victim hold
same time
anything else Herman Savannah we're
standing here playing intolerance is
it's the first time they shared what
happened to them with the court
I would say that is the first time they
shared what happened to them in a public
setting
everyone
some of my clients
[Music]
I don't know but I'm confident about
that when in the original indictment
terney said that there were
co-conspirators that he must have have
Evan had evidence sufficient to
take that charge
according to the file
sex trafficking control
I should say
clearly directing
trafficking
by an adult
so
to other countries
and in any event I think it was evidence
of sex trafficking
it's like how many I don't
obviously there were those who recruited
vulnerable
you should bring it those miners to mr.
Epstein
satisfy mr. Epstein
sexual needs empowered answer or
whatever those needs were and then they
were void
as they do so knowingly who was in the
chain I don't know
what I know they were nervous before
so I don't say what they did whether
whether or what they do knowing whether
it been about
like I don't know
I can't disclose
but whatever I know I know through
attorney-client privilege
I can't I can't I can't make any
statements without asking my clients
with conditions in the clothes
a favor within the package
do I take you with the judging
what do I take from wacky did not
immediately dismiss the charges against
Pepsi
I think he's a very careful very
thoughtful very sensitive
judge I can't say that about all the
judges that I've ever been
many decades but he is I want to say one
other thing about this judge I've been
involved with many victim of impact
statements as always at sentencing
and sometimes the judge lists the victim
speak
kind of shuffles paper
they think it's very disrespectful but
sometimes that occurs in force that did
not occur this morning
I was watching on his judge he listened
carefully he looked at the victims who
were testifying
he'd listened he was paying attention he
was showing respect he was sometimes
making do I just thank you
I'm very very pleased about that
I think we go president
let's like this example
some people call it unique
because generally the victims only have
an option
after
right
matter of law
there was no connection
and yet his court felt
the court applying the early on
to whether or not
have an opportunity
nope
obviously
I'm so glad that he did
by the way some victims are still living
in fear because they're great that
cohort associates or friends or business
people of Jeffrey absolutely might be
out
take action against
I can assure any victim who's living in
fear if you have here and you have a
basis for that theater in other words
someone has threatened you and your
safety in reference to your statements
about mr. Epstein or any knowledge you
may have about what mr. Epstein did you
for any and if anyone has knowledge of
what was done to you you can feel free
to contact me because of your behalf if
you wish I will contact law enforcement
and ask them to follow up because
[Music]
you should not
there is an investigation ongoing and I
want you to feel safe
there's a brother that's crimson
so I have any evidence at all from it
doing evil yes I don't know they chicken
which powerful men with respect you what
happens okay
so I I don't I don't have that venture
like it may come
well I just believe it that anyone
else's a brutal rape his first time
coming
we heard some graphic descriptions as
brutal rape
30 sexual assault Republicans
of this what was a court reporter in the
courtroom
I don't know I didn't ask the corporate
I would assume that's going to be a
public trip that transcript that will be
available to the press that's just an
assumption
I can't state it would have to be the
court that we make that decision some of
the victims are
government well I I did I did it was
reported to be just recently within the
last week that in France there is now
well there's an opening of an
investigation into a French citizen I
won't name him now but you can find it
what associated with mr. Epstein
it's assumption on my part that they're
also looking into what mr. Epstein may
or may not have done in France because
we know we had an apartment there in
Paris but so you would have to ask the
French in French law enforcement
what they're doing
excuse me and yes some of the victims
who are not here
are located outside of the country in
other words they may be since another
country
yes I'd read and statements it alone I
did today transported to it
I don't like to paraphrase a victim's
statement but I will say that yes the
statement that I read on behalf of that
victim indicated that she was
transported a number of times from Texas
to New Mexico to the ranch
ostensibly to play the violin
to get paid for that that's not a
forceful happen
and she was Amaya and she was very very
traumatized by what happened to her
I take very seriously
I'm very glad that there is an
investigation
another bus home
Lorien all the years
what have I seen a ring this big I don't
know how many people
I know that there all occasions
of sex trafficking of minors in the our
Kelly case and I do represent a number
of users of our County so glad that sex
trafficking
I gotta take water
one more question maybe elicit anyone
else have questioned
any doubts about his death I think he
might still be alive and hiding
somewhere I don't have any doubt that
mr.
in a cemetery
with his parents next to him and their
gravestone
no I I think when the medical examiner
said so on the lively whether the cause
of death was suicide then I think it's
totally open questions of the procedure
I noted that that the report today was
that that one video camera
not working was not functioning
there are a lot of questions about why
not
why wasn't it fixed how long was it that
way was this
it's an intentional act don't have to
wait and see for the investigation force
anybody to Porto public opinion can
reach their own
conclusion with or without evidence I'm
a lawyer I think Pedro
but